the Aussie kid we're back man the Aussie
kid is back and you know I must really
no no not here you're not here the
Australian oh I know if you call I'll
call ya'll kid yeah yeah yeah now you
pet your pet I need the whole audio yeah
but before we get in that a couple
things I want to talk to you about if
that's cool yeah well before you do can
we I just didn't elf in there I don't
know about before I know it's I really
want you know such a trip I wanna do
that with each other like I know I have
to try not I mean I I have two addresses
before the listeners like but just if
couch sucking on Jolly Rancher no he's
not everyone I think I'm 50 year old he
was breaking him out you break I got
Invisalign it's [ __ ] it's Frank
Shamrock everybody additionally these -
hey you guys I don't know any big family
finally got em buzzed away I guess your
life title I like I just like what's up
bro what's going on might excuse me
whoop your prices are going on there you
gotta leave them in I won't we men why I
can't talk normally yeah you can or me
sure can't
why leave your bottom ones in NoHo you
sound normal right now they made me
leave bottom ones you thought ones are
good leave the bottom one ha ha ha dude
you get in trouble with your dentist
okay [ __ ] off that's what I have to say
I can't even close my mouth my Mac teeth
with don't touch try chewing like really
[ __ ] up your teeth are gonna go
straight listen Bravo where were we
don't ever just randomly walk up to me
after you got braces and just active
like everything's hunky-dory well
they're in my everything Hong Kong all
normal like like hey man you're talking
to me if I'm you go you to be like we're
going to do this sure did
shut it in there and they're very
noticeable I love them you like yeah
they're super know you can definitely no
you weren't plastic on your [ __ ]
teeth so it's a we a psych you have the
plastic mouthpiece up top and on bottom
yeah you ever go into somebody's house
may have plastic on the couches ah my
friends ones that's yeah that's a New
York thing
uh that's half an American thing that's
also an Italian thing it's also a
terrible thing yeah you'd see that she
hold you literally put there there they
put Platt I know we see through plastic
unless that catches pure gold on it why
the [ __ ] you what are you saving it
because you buy a couch for life
because your couch is five grand or
whatever it is and all five grand
I'm the couches when I was a kid those
things ready to three dollars big yes
luck yeah cleanest folly sometimes my
mother had a living room I wasn't
allowed to go into until I was about 20
yep I know I've jetlag like a my mother
saying you spell no a super jet like
super you know everyone's like that no
you get over jet like it's not a big
deal
oh listen it's the worst it gets to
yesterday I did everything in my power
to try and stay awake I drank seven
espressos I woke up I ran freaking damn
there eight miles with stairs I was just
trying to stay stay awake regulate
yourself an old two of cloth girls
around and I'm at I'm eating I'm eating
all on Third Street and I [ __ ] you not a
metropolitan serghie and I'm phones
I can't I'm falling asleep at the table
yeah my son's like what's going on is my
dad OD and I'm just going in and out of
it yeah you can't people who think like
they torture you with a lack of sleep
you need sleep miss one night of sleep
please come talk to gin how much sleep
did we average would you maybe three
hours a night some nights I did no sleep
is that some nice no sleeping then yeah
probably three our exact route magic
number why I got three I felt like a
million bucks for about the next hour
too why so little sleep just a time
change then we're up all night and then
because you get done with a show you
know you start show at 8:00 and then the
I get down around 10:30 then VIP so your
Adrenaline's up and then you buy just
like what is going on when I go out and
I drink or when we know I don't you know
I don't drink you just want food yeah
they get back the next one we have to be
call times like 5:00 a.m. or 6 a.m. to
fly out the next city like so it's just
like boom boom boom boom boom five and
six AM stop it plastered how long were
those flight three hours maximum yeah
that's how long doing what it almost
felt longer than the shorter one two and
a half from Brisbane to Melbourne was
two and a half from giant male born to
New Zealand three then from the zoo in
the Sydney was to some around there that
didn't seem too bad though I played as
crazy as scheduled sounds and all that
stuff was the best experience of my life
really
the best I got here it's not the best
because I heard you were up there like
and you're like oh I don't [ __ ] need
that Club comic and they're like double
cos Branca with fàbregas [ __ ] whoa whoa
whoa relax but then you got all right
anyway don't crawl is that milk
astronaut smiting their heads off yeah
Ozzy Osbourne you know feeling clouded
with it now wha no chlamydia now hey how
about this I took a you saw the picture
I took was I think I said to you Allah
yeah and I you know the the whatever the
place is called little to play long pine
lone pine sanctuary animal sanctuary
well I picked a picture there and
they're like yet you know they give us
all this access and please to every
skill they to handle the koalas and they
take a picture me and like you know the
only thing we ask is that you post a
picture on social media and Tagus my gap
scores match give me a cute picture with
a koala I'll take whatever you want and
then in the title I put a few things you
know that koalas you know I was jokester
I'm like Dale has chlamydia yeah and
that literally hours later they called
our tour manager Simon shoutout to
shrimp they were like hey shop has take
that down there you can affect the
mission like people are gonna want to
come they think our koalas have
chlamydia oh no like just ain't
happening
nah maybe and I said you tell them that
quality did have chlamydia you can talk
to him has chlamydia how can i Oliver
got a runny dick and you know they're so
on back they these ones actually don't
there's a few that don't and ours are
one of the few okay you know what I'm
not affecting your admission of the
Koala now is that a baby koala what was
that both groan for ground pretty small
milk out like old men all of them and
they don't move fast at all so I'm
moving at LX long until your digit in
that anus on accident yeah digit anus is
closing here wait why did you get why
did you get your digits because it is on
a pee test is what I quote because this
koala Wrangler was like you have to put
to put your hands together like a like a
bathroom like well my fingers are [ __ ]
up can really do a basket
nice girl like this so I made like duh
like I was catching a punt yeah and then
she said I'm lying on me put the old
weight around that
and that ring singing ah boy and that's
when of course is all cool me with here
yeah yeah another coma in Talos I didn't
think I'm like why have you doing she's
like well we're okay there's the problem
so you need to I guess it said do so so
I'm that guy like if I'm in my past when
I've been with a woman sometimes you get
a girl starts to explore that area
clinch it up she's well sometimes you
get a girls like I got long nails but
I'm I'm a little drunk and I might just
going in South here and she starts a
Roman and you're like you know what
you're you're linger in there with that
with that middle finger or that ring sex
with this quality on my rumpy-pumpy is
I'm taking care of business and often
did it and you're like hey know what the
oil but all it did yeah I followed you
all there high all the time off
eucalyptus leaves really that's what I
thought all the time but they're also
filled yeah they were all chill like
sloth I'm like what are they on [ __ ]
nyquil would you guys give these things
and then the kangaroos were so used to
humans they didn't give a [ __ ] about
it's like that one laying down I'll just
I'm just gonna cuddle them he's like do
what every one of the things I can do
nothing like really going to rip my
name's up so just like he's like if you
want to get down I was like takes and
[ __ ] Australian leeches or whatever I
just went down the side grab them grab
my Cola that was a great video bong a
great video but what eats koalas no I
don't know they did I don't think to
have any real predators really but so
are they plentiful what I think so I
don't know maybe a lot of hey don't look
like the guy man or when I gotta [ __ ]
I did little dick jokes I didn't [ __ ]
study hey while you were there you know
you went to my college you had an
essential almost a sanctuary they have
these things literally [ __ ] in one
tank is the most venomous snake on earth
tiger snake or I forget what it was
banded Krait something like eels just as
nasty as we can state their exact this
crazy Python there's [ __ ] uh
Tasmanian devils which were crazy
looking at each other but old chin then
there's a there's a dingo basically
another word for your common dog to hold
chin oh my god obsessed with this dog
took 30 selfies with the dog was it
could you pet it nas in a cage yeah
dingoes are wild dog and dog stands a
border collie would I'm Stuart yeah hey
bro kind of muscular all the yellow
muscular dog all over ya ugly godly
anyways that's a dog there's bats giant
[ __ ] Fox bats that were like this
rake and then it looked like they had
like tires wrapped around they were so
sick
Oh Jane had no interest in any of that
he was like dude you gotta check this
and I want champion all the elderly dogs
sure look at me you really get away from
that dingo man hey you want to suck that
get away from that Australian dog hate
it over here chin I'm good anyway more
of course be more into the Fox Pat I
need you to address how dangerous of
snake is instead of taking pictures with
the [ __ ] dog that's [ __ ] I start
making racist jokes
what was the deer of course you did
Korea are mouthwatering you can water
lucky why are we Cisco into the dog the
contractor is making your tummy rub a
hell I should say I did this bit on I
mean I do this on stage so out she was
obsessed with this dingo and I was a eh
eh worried thinking teriyaki chunked out
and he's like Jackie's not [ __ ] Korea
that's true it was really true sir it's
very it's very Japanese is funny man so
you uh you saw the dog and you saw the
dog and you were like mmm it's pretty oh
very pretty nice dinner dog those as
soon as you got to play the guys like
you guys got one day for you it's really
day sleep heels would like to see a
koala Mike so it's the only reason I
came yeah that's low no Crocs
you go to go to the outlet you were in
the outback writing I saw nothing a lot
say well I'd love to see all of them
again but there's a couple things that
surprised me
let's just get this out of the way now
the weather so the weather was nice and
big a line in Sydney okay Sydney's was
just like la New Zeeland was super nice
stay on Lord of the Rings been very
beautiful place and we barely saw some
that but just flying in and I saw Sydney
like Opera House and all that um but Mel
Melbourne and Brisbane and freezing
really it was cold
is it there winter right now Haskell huh
and then hey in Sydney I know it'll be
Tokyo as in Omaha as in
as in what very crowded or as in
Japanese do did I send na when I say
this yeah I'll try it all agent is
always yo yeah so so was it mostly
Chinese I think it was Chinese yeah
great deal of Chinese auto Chinese
Cemetery in Beijing Koreans to write
product and because they you know its
rates close I had no idea right so yeah
everywhere I had no idea is linking
right now relax bro I thought I figure
just be all white people in a couple
Aborigines like in there yep just like
real short dog that's what I would have
liked dog abrir the originals I call me
originals bro when I say that plates
taking over Asians it takes everything
over yeah everything yeah now I am as
well after what we had then yeah I would
have guessed that was the last meal we
had there dumplings dumplings ah
weddings with in with it whole chicken
and light rice with chopsticks what
happened oh I asked lights got ran out
man what thought stever would be rolling
over in his grave I saw none that's a
little bit like Vancouver Vancouver is
oh no I've been Bank little nothing
mighty I've been in Vancouver right it's
nothing like any Cooper Sydney I never
heard that oh it's like they won the war
Nadeem it is crazy fan I was shocked I
was shocked Sydney I was shot at Chinese
population find out what the Chinese
population of Sydney six billion just
everywhere you look he was like that we
stayed downtown it was a beautiful area
but it was like staying and Korean down
here Wow crazy right but that's amazing
I was third in the list two hundred
eighty seven thousand nine hundred fifty
two I have a lot of Irish there was a
lot of time aggregor fans out there wow
this is surprising right yes very
surprising that's a great deal of
Chinese I had some great food good times
it was a breakthrough for me as an
artist is that the best thing I've ever
done because what I love six shows in
four days in but it was like I was
important but it was like macho slide
shows in four days for Dickey but it was
like I just I'm rat back
Cedar's yeah madam body how you guys
good there's new stuff yeah you did that
setter when you do the road like that
you come away with a whole new Act it
was great you know yeah so something
more satisfying but what was different
too is like with finding the kids there
might be we might do a show where I
might be a little tired I might be a
loss or you might be able to tell you
I'm not but we find it but together we
hold each other we hold each other up
like like now your Anatomy or I'll bring
it you know I'm saying we figure but
this one like I said the responsibility
of those there were especially theatres
or like you better show the [ __ ] that's
what stand-up is when you go out there
alone you're it's you you know for an
hour and they want you to solve those
problems really great thank you you guys
solve the problem for for an hour which
is make us [ __ ] laugh to our son
yeah they see two hours and then the
last night because I do we'd have these
mean greets last night I was just
excited to be Donald just happy to be
there
my the last signature best show I've
ever had hands down if anything I've
ever done in your last show too and then
we did and I feel like it's fine getting
a group yeah I told my was exactly the
state way long greens again know when
come back at her next time but for those
VIPs we did the VIP mean greet and
there's like 85 up I stayed for another
90 minutes just answered questions like
talking to them chillin how great is
that you get energy from that belt is
fun yeah it's what you're made of him
then it's where your answer you it's a
little bit historic because you are the
first athlete to do that it's kind of
crazy okay yeah I mean it really is it's
exciting
I couldn't believe those crowds it hit
me when I saw those crowds it hit me
that this was what you were doing there
I was like what theaters people going
crazy crazy was amazing school in and
the ones you want to go back one I will
I told the Brad who runs nice promotions
yeah I told him I'm going back one to
you one see it's great boom boom we're
gonna take Phi tourniquet that we need
to man don't be scared I'm not but as
far as growing the brand they see for
myself and everything I'm telling you
that once you see it like you're there
on with your own eyes you realize what
it does hmm and now I want to do more of
it only go to Europe on do so the stuff
is brilliant in this Ireland UK yeah it
was great it was great man mark on end
up win the fight predicted it like we
was you just saying to hear I'm like I'm
not mean I think but the Lewis versus
hunt I think I like Lewis is just
I was his bad man look my Lois got tired
my right he always gets tired yeah heavy
weights Mark Hunt is time tired and both
tired but yeah so that was good and then
up there was weird is Ivan tax rollin
like dude I'm because Brogan did shows
out there like dude I'm so [ __ ] tired
man before I was like right in the
middle that we're at was you're like you
know I'm saying like you so are they
ahead by 12 hours 17 hours so their head
by 70 now it's Tuesday's morning they're
okay that's a very difficult thing to
get used to so there's one show I just
like didn't brother was like I done
dealt with a man he's like I stretch I
do this they're having shadowbox without
being a sponsor music I supposed to be
on the industry I'm just running in
circles in my green room yeah they're
just sprinting that yeah you got
accepted oh yes I heard the Tom Cruise I
know this from Artie Lange Tom Cruise
will be done with the take his assistant
comes over gives him a jump rope he
starts jumping rope to wake up Hicks
that's just how he keeps himself up
he'll just Charlotte ran yeah for me at
school because you know me and chin
spent some time together but Osbert you
know a lot of time on my own it's rare
I'm ever on my own yeah family here yeah
I'm with you I'm dealing with my friends
in LA I'm armed with my brother you like
it I kind of liked him he gave me a lot
of times I think I'll reflect on things
and get more ideas like what I want to
do next and then like there was a
morning you know cuz I couldn't sleep in
so I'd wake up about 4:30 5:00 a.m.
every morning and then try and find a
coffee not walk the city you ever heard
what of this expression woodshedding
so woodshedding something that the jazz
musicians used to always use so that
what they would do is they so you play a
show and you'd be a jazz musician could
be a great jazz musician and then they
would decide well that they got to put
all that stuff aside and come up with a
new sound and they would go into what's
called a woodshed where they'd spend a
lot of time alone and just play their
horn all day okay and spend time alone
for a month or whatever might way - well
no but it's not really if you're working
on something so it's the same idea like
it's important for you to be alone
sometimes when you're coming up with
ideas because you're in your own head
you're with yourself but plus people
will sway things too
stupider like I found some stuff where
you know I've had people help me on
certain things and then I would get my
cat that's not how I would say it that's
not anything I would do and I didn't
realize until I was saying it out loud
like that's not what I would do so I had
to recon finding your own voice because
it's really hard not in the beginning
when you're doing anything artistic
you're going to you're going to mimic it
immediately after you're going to be
influenced by that and then you you
create your own music after a while I
thought it was interesting is that the
promoter Brad who they deal with I mean
talking to everyone the biggest of the
big and you say me how the like times
are changing as far as touring in the
touring industry goes because he goes
let's say I bring in you know name an
older artist like I don't know naima
older are the Eagles yes there go the
Eagles that's a good one so there's huge
right Eagles still the Eagles but he's
gonna have to they have to do press in
the morning he's you have to put up
posters and do billboards and he goes he
was an I take [ __ ] from the pros like
this he goes but I'll do a guy like you
who you know your social media your
podcast will sell all our tickets I
don't have to invest any money and may
decide the flights egos or these
youtubers you saw tell me about some of
these youtubers have 10 million 20
million subscribers he goes they will
come and he was you know your bounce all
around they will come into Sydney and do
seven days three shows a day sold out
you know hunch promotion I do know how
much he was 0 just the games changing he
goes it's people have their built their
their own promoters of social media you
know so I don't it cost me you know
chump change to bring these guys here
because they're selling themselves to
crabbing I don't have no one's doing
radio in the morning no I don't have but
not putting up billboards of these old
artists right because so I'm using these
youtubers guys like you I'll do q and
A's with celebrities and it just sells
himself can you tweet it out that's
amazing and I was as soon as youtubers
did you know is it like cheap thrills
wear heels no man like they they have a
team behind them it's a really really
good production crazy man that's
incredible Mac ready yeah the whole game
is changed yeah it's great talking them
it's great talking to us you know I make
money hand over fist because I bring you
out gives what you cost me fine
here he was I didn't take any sales to
sell your tickets if you did on your
podcast which is for you and me is free
yeah that's like to hold the whole games
change it he's liking people because I
wouldn't look at people who don't who
can't sell tickets fart like that now
because I'm not putting the time and
it's like I'm just cuz I can just go
over hearing reg making you tweet this
out myself to you entire industries are
dying
that's why publicists back in the day a
publicist would do a you pay them
literally six grand a month oil to get
you into certain magazines and just get
you out there on you'd go and do
promotional stuff and now it's you know
you got these youtubers and people like
that or that I'm out of this podcast
where you don't have to relieve myself
like I just booked a show in Phoenix on
July like 18th or something like that
that we dove and the venue goes hey if
we fly in early do press a I'm not going
to need to see I don't do that yeah we
want me cuz it doesn't work like that
I'm not your traditional comic where I
was an open mic and I'm building a fan
base I come with the stand I'm not I'm I
can do press and sell someone on my you
know Ratigan girl you already have
that's not know you were coming anyway
that's not what we do yeah it's just in
talking to promote these really you
talking about he worshipped Coldplay I
mean you're talking the biggest in the
world he's like I just don't do that
anymore
he was awake for everything he goes cuz
if you hear an ad on whatever you like
I'm like going to go buy that ticket
like you're gonna know these yeah social
media yeah it was brilliant it we got
smart dude that Brad was a smart smart
dude man he knows who's fighting it's
good really good they don't even do
marquees really Australia really yeah I
guess everything's already done and set
so they now maybe at do it at a time
they've they ran such a tight ship like
we'd flying the airport
here's your ticket is this go to this
VIP lounge is your food
toffee get off thing everything was
taken care yeah I had to wear nothing's
a well-oiled machine manual well energy
and I was do I went I told shrimp a case
I know what did you're a beast at this
you know yeah realized something I'm
used to dealing with 2030 people you
know egos and Yuri he goes your time out
dancers pyrotechnics all
oh it's you and Chan that's it yeah he
goes this is like my real and he's like
this is it like we all would you think
things like I'm just all right let's do
it
and it was buspar can great man that's
amazing so he was with you the whole
ball through everywhere but made Lily we
go through security just flash them
right when Wow
custom everything that's incredible you
like let's make sure you get food you do
this you do he knew all the lady knew
everything no great white shark does no
guess it wasn't so next time maybe you
do add a day off day day off that makes
sense yeah maybe but the days when I was
like like when we flew when I was at a
show that day like I don't like I don't
know I like waiting around yeah I'll be
like do a show and then I don't know
take a look I would I would have done at
next time I do just one big show in
Sydney one big big show let that be my
plan but we'll see either way man I
decided that the whole business thing in
talking like that and he he's in the
state's all time doing similar stuff I
started show like the dynamic in the way
it's changes crazy to me out tonight and
then I was like you gotta tell me who's
difficult to work with he got to tell me
and I'm not gonna rat because I don't
want laundry you know big laundry up it
but it was fascinating oh yeah I was
like what I have just one very famous
Tigers
he's exhausting because he comes here
and you know we you know how we have a
shuttle for does not show they had like
you know those little those fans like
this black man feels much like mercy
fans yeah so instead of tour bus we use
that and goes you know so we use that
for every one we should fuel them load
people Enya's well this one guy who we'd
all know he goes he likes to drive so he
refuses to go with us and he doesn't
know where he's going
we drive on the right side so she's
getting in multiple accidents he didn't
take it he's late everywhere he's
hitting on all the girls nice yeah he's
like she's exhausting because we will
never have them back no it really don't
sell tickets he goes I know a thousand I
don't think is yeah because it does not
matter he doesn't sell that every and
the funny thing about Holly was the same
thing you can be famous a [ __ ] if you're
a pain in the ass as soon as one movie
doesn't do well Matt can't do it no
thanks you can often you saying this guy
cute would keep hitting on the girl
being a really girl when the tours
drives around get in like what's up girl
keep grabbing her like a man the [ __ ]
are you doing what are you doing man
old origins and older gentleman
typically get past a point of giving a
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah yeah and if what
else was weird out there is there's uh
that wasn't used to it there's no
there's no tipping really so like and
not that the service is bad we don't
have to work for tips
it's not like they forgot a lot of slow
if we got a lot of [ __ ] right chin like
ask for this Diet Coke price several
times just for that one boy she's 45
yeah do you know about Australia's
history right like how it started a
little bit but this is what else was
weird to me be is New Zealand you know
New Zealand is different currency than
Australia do you know that I didn't know
that so I lost real cash
once you go get coffee and the girl is
out you know this girl was huge younger
but she was took no type of [ __ ] girl
ready girl and I saw I ordered out there
you just got strong flat lights
it was [ __ ] brilliant so the best
coffee I've ever had in every city
there's more cop stuff than you're
talking that there's Soph I got that
text great coffee really tired he would
love it everywhere coffee was [ __ ]
great yeah I didn't have one bad copy
anyways I got New Zealand I go to pay
and she goes what are you doing give me
cash for the coffee she goes this in New
Zealand I'm it yeah I know here's your
cash you think that's Australian money
man I went yeah and she goes
we're not Australian we're not being
Australian part of it she goes we have a
different [ __ ] current dammit you do
she owes Oh God and she goes you think
we think I sound like something from us
gentlemen listen to me because now you
know we're on Granby rather joking but
you can tell I went listen to me you
sound identical to an Australian you all
sound the same she owes oh my [ __ ]
god
and she goes Mary could you deal with
this guy so come out here and deal with
funny I chose we sell all the same we
couldn't be more different
you sound like identical they definitely
I'm talking different there's in the
hotel we were joking I would you sound
like is Owen you keep that [ __ ]
coffee warm I'm gonna lose [ __ ] ATM
and get your stupid [ __ ] Newseum cats
she went get that [ __ ] cash I went
and you're not getting a tip how about
that
you're not you know said she doesn't
accept it she goes yell we have paid
more hourly of it that's fine that's
fine slice service sucks now when he got
the catch
she was great that's great that's great
man yeah I knew about the cozy but tell
me a little I was working I know about
rally as I stated just was Austria was a
dominated by English right
well yes but do you know what it's past
how Australia do you know who the first
people the first English people in
Australia worked you know what they mean
so they're from England because I drama
originally yeah yeah but do you know why
they went from England to all the way to
Australia it's an interesting what's a
various dating nope what really
interesting it was a penal colony so
when you were a criminal
the brigly sit with his engineer in a
boat there that's right and they would
just send you and so Australia
originally started as a penal colony and
then of course you know families would
come and all that stuff but you know
basically and then of course you had
explorers to study the you know the
Outback yeah for the most part that's
the infamous founding of Australia which
is in a lot of ways which is to their
credit because Australians are never
from my experience and the things I've
read and talked to Australians and all
they're not a cocky group of people
right very humbling or cocky at all and
they're really fun there's a 95 ever
even if you made a mistake or you said
some you know like you know I write
they're great the [ __ ] great because
they sold around the word legend all too
much but they're great haha but they
can't but because they can't be like oh
yeah we Rock were worthy superior we ran
the world no they started the penal
colony so there's a there's a built-in
sort of modesty and that's a global
major to the uttering command right yeah
yeah was a lot of people don't realize
it's pretty wild
yeah and then they were able to sort of
be far away enough from the crown from
England to have their own independence
to create their own country so they
didn't really have to deal with British
oppression back then taxation and things
like that they kind of they kind of were
left alone it's just too far to launch a
thousand ships to let me sit yeah so
just kind of became their own thing
Sydney's right I guess Sydney they're
telling me because everywhere we lean
how I go how what's real estate like
there yes Sydney's crazy cuz I am sure
and probably a lot because does a lot of
immigration Chinese immigration thanks
I'm innocent because people in China
died want to put their money necessarily
in their own economy they want to put it
in a Stabler you know a place like you
know Australia United States and stuff
like that which is what drives a lot of
the prices in Vancouver and in New York
it's a lot of Chinese I wish I went to
this restaurant in New Zealand I just
wanted like all I wanted New Zealand
before the ship says we landed I'd like
two hours for the show so like I just
want a good meal I get a steakhouse
unlike a really nice meal before I go
and I went right across the street at
forget what is the Metro sit not Metro
City what is that City walk or something
so he's like you'll Universal CityWalk
that thing went right across the waiter
this restaurant looked you know it was
in a chain it was an original restaurant
I went in there and I decided to bar
Nass it was like this young guy on it
they had a crazy menu or fish and steak
I went what's the best thing here in
goes I would get this in this I went and
I is there any way you could just like
give me like portion language try it all
yeah we can do that
oh really had the best [ __ ] meal yeah
I'd like fish sliders ceviche these
tacos course [ __ ] my pants after but not
a great combination yeah things man yeah
I'm so nice
that's beautiful I made a mistake you
know a lot of steak and a lot of wine
last night and old 5000 Bry doesn't do
well with that I will cut up job I woke
up in a full sweat really high yeah you
go body temperature was spiked I was
four and morning and I was like standing
on an Internet my heart I can use you
though I ate at home my father-in-law
cooks a mean [ __ ] steak chicken cuz I
just started wolfing it down
drinking couple bottles of wine vodka
cheese and then ran it out off with some
goat milk chocolate deep chocolate ice
cream
goat milk I see what the [ __ ] wrong
with you guys so good what's the regular
but where's the way to life I don't eat
kept there Calabasas shel why don't you
eat dairy III can't do the cow thing I
have an allergy to it bull-fucking-shit
hey you have braces and you refuse the
cheese and dairy yes [ __ ] you right now
no I eat I eat coward I mean I
cheap and go here no I've seen you eat
regular old age shut up read it alright
sometimes I feel [ __ ] then it gives me
it gives me problems I have talking is
charge you have changed got braces and
you only cheetah I'm getting delicate my
eyes done and I need every bit of my
seven half to eight hours doing I need
to man I took ambien ton playing out
there so I've slept straight ten hours
woke up had like four hours left is
great the ways there I had chin take
when he's on how about chin thought we
were [ __ ] smuggling cocaine or some
somewhat here just take these so you
sleep the pill is tidy on it's the
quarter of a tic-tac yeah there's a
[ __ ] fragment yep you're Chinese like
we're in line is I click around like a
mine asking to smuggle drugs in yes what
are you looking around like this he's
all I don't know man once they check
that what if they check the speck in
your pocket then you deserve to get
caught he's like nah yeah anything no
why would you take Unitas I'm just
nervous
I got paranoid hang with it you [ __ ]
but God and you for not only a drug mule
I was gonna decide yeah you should have
seen him sweating I'm like what are you
doing already I didn't give you some
[ __ ] cocaina
Muslim your Brum / hey how about they
didn't work for me I took full a big boy
I took how are you I tell you a picture
in a handy boy and there's like two or
three of them I took those two I'm
sitting there watching TV I'm like I am
wide awake that's lady I'm like eh can I
get a couple beers down beers like I
mean more crunking I feel like dancing
and then I took two more didn't work ah
drooling on my mouth like to not fall
asleep when you big boy you big boy it
takes a lot uh in my buddy went to
Mexico my buddy went to Mexico I got a
couple friends were what's the word they
like to chase certain sensations so they
bring a lot of cash down in Mexico sugar
talks you know it speaks and well he's
got a bunch of cash packed in his bag
and all of a sudden he's walking through
big old German Shepherds [ __ ] chomped
on him he said what the [ __ ] dogs dog is
literally trained to sniff cash over the
bag sir that guy goes like this looks at
him
sees the cash and reaches in he just
reaches in and grabs it he pulls out and
goes
just took it from ya listen Mexico yup
dogs dogs train sniff cache and how
about that how about Jim we go through
Australian Customs and all the [ __ ] and
New Zealand Testaments doing it stop
fortunate spots in LA for two hours
oh come on why I did it you no idea
maybe there's a sleeping pill well maybe
what do you mean why two hours two
different lines so I had to go through
you know when we like an immigration
thankful as a random [ __ ] I don't
know so we got your passport drew and
then you scan your face yeah for
whatever reason I'm sure they let you go
through read it right away me the next
my ex dying so I went to another wait
they scan your face what is this is new
brain your life though just go to scan
your face go don't fill up I don't know
if I want the government knowing what my
face is Oh lacks Eddie Bravo [ __ ] you
I'm not kidding they got a data to have
about anyways your camp they film every
facial recognition it's great it makes
it harder for [ __ ] terrorists to get
through now yeah they do all this map
it's believed you face off and then they
switch their faces ready so really so
your face you got hey you got Terry's
face huh I think I do on my Montana part
of my mustache that's amazing it looks
like you look at that knowledge of
that's so interesting
well yeah maybe maybe some numbers came
up on the fate on the spatial
relationship between your nose and your
mouth all that weird [ __ ] that they do
maybe that's interesting
did you so so mark hunt won the fight
was there any are there any of the other
fights that you did you watch the fights
there what uh well we were flying when
the flights were going on so I would get
updates and saw some of it on my phone
cuz I got I fought this weekend you know
that or not this weekend but this week I
know you texted it and I just as I know
where you're gonna go with this yeah and
you rejecting I ran to Luke Rockhold
and I just to put a stop to ice but I
don't care Andy she ain't you not text
me back after that yeah well that's a
real friend you know I hate this we go
ahead well I mean maybe the people would
like to hear they might you know I mean
I mean I know you're over fighting but
maybe the peeps would like to hear it no
I mean look I walked the earth bro I
know man okay and you know I train I
you know I spar right okay okay first of
all tell a story go to what smirk off
your face I'm already annoyed all right
honored still hey hey young but tell our
fans killer a serious story
tell me about wife's eyes mark oh oh
they wash the whole thing so you IV Shh
well I wish I wish you'd leave those
brakes in so I could grab your teeth I
know be fun I know
[ __ ] off let me try them on no can I say
that your hate and there's no [ __ ]
way run
[ __ ] that I've never let your similar
teeth we do get yourself some visit line
let me tell you're sorry see if I like
them no because they're fitted to the
teeth they won't fit you
Wow between you'll ruin them let me try
no you got a big mouth and I'm not gonna
let you well so I don't want your mouth
on my mouth I don't know how that I like
him you gotta get a face broke cuz I
tell my stories ya go you know what man
I sparred Luke Rockhold now let me
finish I was a hit mitt least he's
getting some work in he got in there out
floppy he got in there with some rent
with some mitts and he began to move
around with me who was on mitts form
what childís yzz I was that glove was a
great way McCall's home it's for me okay
Lou copies said to himself this [ __ ]
actor can move I need to learn something
well this kid can [ __ ] crack I think
I heard him say that
he's probably chomping a bit to get some
cage time he's child right at your town
all son I look up Lucas Lucas feeling
all kinds of froggy he's hopping around
alright he's hungry do you say I'm not
I'm not busy I got both lines but
exactly what I said to him and I go well
well well if it ain't the [ __ ] long
Mongoose you got that big those long
arms the old bloody boy let's see what
happens with your worry boy yeah let's
see what happens how did you go I got a
better hook than bisman we saw that in
for you you know why actors would jump
out the ring what do i do I go this is
my rainbow you know I'm saying this is
my ring and a lot of guys who hide in
the corner control the center of the
ring so I moved around with Lou now
loopy and big and very good Luke a fish
he is big and he's a
he's also south oh you've had you don't
use the traditional cellphone yeah the
best kicks jujitsu and strike in the
world does it was weird I and I didn't
I'll be honest with you I didn't put a
lot of leather on his body or hazel and
hurt himself yeah anyway he put some
leather on my body though he was tapping
me around a little bit and at the end of
it then I started here come on gallant
come on Brian you got this and I looked
over at mr. Daniel Cormier brought up
the set of us the other night yeah also
also a fighter I don't know if you know
Daniel Cormier he was he was filming for
you but I guess he didn't send it to you
it goes clock shop I got I got your boy
he's ready for you as I was getting as I
was getting tossed around as I was
getting batted about as you would expect
and then I ran I finally got very tired
and I ran at DC and I and I tried to
hide but he was over the ropes and I
began to and he put his arm around me
and Luke didn't take that as he was like
ma'am still going to tackle your body
yeah and he had to beat my body up a
little bit didn't ever tell you anything
about him fighting soon do you talk
about any of that
uh well I wonder if I could say he's got
a big thing going on so it's a good
thing for him so yes outside the rink so
I was and I won't spill those movies and
modeling stuff like time and stuff like
that so I hear that yeah yeah yeah so so
I don't know that he is I need to get
the [ __ ] in there he does looks great
he's been he's training he's he's
sparring you know theses always change
applause oh yeah get in the [ __ ] I'm
sure he'll be ready for the for the if
anything happens you'll Whitaker I'm
sure he's by the way that's what he said
that's a fight he would have to take and
then he's got he'd be the first one yes
and he's so he's aware of that and so
funny something I'm drop similar doing
Lucas Mousasi think that's what they
want they want it they wanna but I think
Misaki is doesn't sign this gun right
because Musashi wants more money
yeah and so did Luke there this will
weird Holden yes yes but I think the
fight for Luke would obviously he could
never say no to yo al Whitaker of
somebody [ __ ] yeah but that's a lot like
that's what the odds of that having good
right what he needs to get one on the
books yes people forget about it so if
you were managing him you haven't fight
masazi
what would you have them wait wait for
what can I
I didn't title shot no can you wait he
can't like us dad not down he has to win
right right then I can't get why him
again well you know if what you know
what yeah let's see what happens with
Kelvin it depends when Luke wants fight
because Weidman Kelvin Gastelum are
fighting tell when you spy Weidman
that's the main event in uh in uh in uh
New York so I think the fight nights or
Fox card if Kelvin get by Weidman which
a lot of people think you know won't be
on it although its hometown but why if
Kelvin your bathroom Kelvin where salute
makes a lot of sense hmm Luke's nothing
to [ __ ] with and I said this out in
Australia you know a lot of fan
questions like do you think workers be
champ and I do that needs to be champ I
think you think he's that good
I think I think Whitaker gets by you
I'll oh yeah I know right
I think I think use by ul if you were to
match up with Bisbing you know it's a
very tough fight for visiting he matches
up well with them right he's Luke's a
bad matchup for him that's his toughest
test I said I was Dale honest with the
crowd I went when you bright chin I went
to said you know you I like him yet ul I
like Assad against visiting after I gets
a little hairy
Mousasi and Rocco would be tough matchup
for but you're saying for Whitaker yeah
okay I think you will be champ yeah a
forty five faces Luke or nothing well
Luke is so confident too he's just such
a that's a problem dude did you go out
that's why you got knocked out yeah cuz
he doesn't he doesn't really take
somebody to take businesses it's one of
his best assets and one was worst yeah
yeah give me a liability mmm uh yeah
he's remarkably tall you know he's ever
been a 6-4-3 yo every big yeah an
athletic is [ __ ] Brennan that's the one
thing I like treat I've seen him but
when I saw him kind of working out and I
looked at his you know he's very
physically imposing I mean he's a big
guy yeah I heard you talking about a
[ __ ] creme de la creme yeah five oh
yeah world yeah yeah I don't know why
you're surprised like this no no he just
looks like he looks the part like he
looks exactly how you want to answer yes
yes ridiculous I said what's weird about
Luke I know you know I love you Luke I
just can't and I was talking about us on
stage I'm not I cannot get why she's not
a
megastar he has the looks he's dated
celebrities he has the skills there's
something about him that people don't
like it might in might be that in this
is why I think I can't you know say for
sure I think it's the cockiness it's a
guy who has it all but they don't see
him you know being home excited might be
off so that he doesn't really put
himself out there either right does he'd
hit him do a lot of press I don't see
him doing this fuss so funny he said
because he was sitting there we were
after we had moved around in silly and
stuff we were kind of leaned on the rows
talking and these girls who were taking
a class at glove works they started it
was just they they nickels are dancing
yeah it started well they just started
dancing on Moorhead and he just started
he just started going
he started chuckling cuz it was so
obvious that they were they there was
the silverback and they were going to
try to shake their work great-looking
dude he's such a good guy you can be
mark what what point but that that is
and what I'm saying is that he has with
that kind of power it feels like it he
was managed the right way or if he got
out there more you know it's not this
has nothing to his management it's a
personality issue well on things I don't
know people if he does enough for people
to even get to know his personality he
seems to be not very much in yeah in the
limelight right
he doesn't seem to do a lot like had he
done get Dancing with the Stars cuz I'd
have him do that for well I won't have
him do that oh my god why do you hate
why do you hate him why James what is
his career over what do you mean that's
that's a huge show he would come out of
hand oh no no dance on TV so he did he
did a million-dollar matchmaker and
almost ruin his career
I don't know it went horrible for what
they but but dancing I'm physical mmm if
you're in the mill of pursuing a world
title fight and you're going to dedicate
three months your life to Dancing with
the Stars it's three months you know who
did that three days fans and know who up
to that Chuck Liddell Randy Couture
Jerry Rice there's one thing they all
have in common side Spade they're all
retired they're all [ __ ] old it's race
you're going out to pasture if you do
that you're a b-list maybe c-list
celebrity yeah that would kill his
career and also what you don't get
personally on the [ __ ] dancing well
they taught them and watched a lot of it
but you know I dad if I'm three months
if I'm his manager he is not touching so
what would you have him do
I would have them gone rogue haven't
come on here there's no bigger shows I'd
have them go on I'd have them GQ do a
piece on titties in the style and
surfing
I'd have Markham different way I would
hire a publicist for Luke right he needs
his own publicist
if anyone listened this if you're a big
star and you see you should not rely on
the USC's publicist team and marketing
team to tell your story so see a guy
like Luke he looks like a [ __ ]
superhero you know the skills are
backing up
he's a former champ yep he has
everything well he's got some babies
know where he's got some big things in
the works but if it you know if the big
things like movie and stuff that's not
it no no I think it's you know I'm
saying yeah yeah but I agree but I think
he's got some big things in the works
that will happen you know right now so
this all might be a moot point because
he might be on his way if he's got the
right representation and they had some
imagination they should know the stuff
yeah you know but they it's a tricky
thing how much time do you spend doing
that how much time do you spend fighting
well here's the tricky thing to does
give the personality to do it you know
there's some there's some guys with
there's a reason why they're not out
there the reason why the UFC goes we
don't set up interviews for them because
it hurts the more that it helps them you
know people can't relate to that or
maybe he's not good on me like maybe he
gets nervous everybody says the wrong
thing or maybe it's too cocky like it's
killing us we can't put them on there
yeah I don't know I don't know I don't
either I don't need it but it's on him
but there's 80 doesn't give a [ __ ]
yeah then that's beyond that might
that's more of who don't give a [ __ ]
yeah but then you can't complain when
you don't get a title shot if she goes
you do nothing to market yourself you
can't expect us to do this especially
after you lose it it's a sport but it's
also show business oh yeah more than
ever in yeah more than ever after you
take care of me yeah he's thinking about
girl I kidnapped everything everything
yeah but yeah you know sunlight with the
crowd I cannot figure out why he's not
why isn't crossover that superstar is it
everything nearly just he lost one he
doesn't talk trash though he didn't do
anything doesn't touch trash
yeah but not it's not like it's honest
yeah it's like these
talks on the strap yeah I just can't
figure it out like Mighty Mouse I can
figure out timing there you go
Luke I can't figure out how do you see
that one with gasolin and Luke and Luke
I would put my my handbook
hey see how Gaston does against Kyle
like wide me my gas one being Vitor does
nothing for me I don't give a [ __ ] about
that I'm not you know I think Gaston
stuff specially had I think seventy you
know he's a monster you know she has
weight is she's there 85 you know
they're big guys like once you get to
the upper and I've seen this too Rogan
Eddie Bravo like everyone wants to jump
on this ban on these bad wagons like
this I'm just not I need to see how he's
gonna do against a bigger bigger dude
like Wyman's a bigger dude can wrestle
you know and and can strike so this
would be if he destroys weiming then we
got some of our hands if he really
struggles with widening the lineman's of
top six guy we'll see but then after
that you know got like Whitaker's you
can give a guy like kelvin a lot of
[ __ ] bums who saucing him a lot of
drums
Rockhold a lot of [ __ ] bronze his
being a lot of problems you're not
taking Bisbee down so you look at this
top sash when I'm the top five I don't
like his odds really there but
everyone's to jump right in oh he's next
camp [ __ ] he knocked out both sp2 yeah
well it was a candidate thing that
surprised everybody how's the big one is
it you thought my kid even one foot in
one foot out over trained to shoot a
show for the History Channel even a lot
he was into a lot I guess yeah I mean
she looks so he looks amazing don't get
me wrong he looks amazing all I'm saying
is I'm not ready to crown the next king
of the middleweight division until you
beat a guy like rock like Mousasi like
you l ike record fact is big thick field
top five it's a I thought five were
[ __ ] Tom yeah yeah that's a six
that's all I'm saying
I think he does have the skills [ __ ] yes
tell them the monster I love watching
fight yeah I'm get going for start
crowning mother should i widen fight in
New York's would be a tough one for him
now if he just goes out and [ __ ]
smashes him like you did Kennedy or Vito
and I ran off to the races
because after you have to beat Wyman
you're right there
you're right what's right widen rank
five six now probably six yeah well I'm
in Scott Irwin this is why I'm against
the ropes yeah you lose this one
probably go to a 5 X Lion pressure yeah
a lot of pressures this weekend in
Hawley respect Korea that's this weekend
why do you say a lot of for Holly me
she's lost three in a row yeah he's for
Holly should win this tough fight she
should though yeah
but [ __ ] man useful in a row it's kind
of if it was any other division you get
in your walking papers with the new UFC
I don't know but you know kicking around
the face like [ __ ] and being the poster
girl for that and what you know she came
her next fight should begin cyborg at 45
beekeeper but [ __ ] man and her enemy was
exert of a she got hit twice after the
after the Bell
so there was a lot of doesn't matter
she's a lot but luckily the job got a
job it doesn't matter is it did a good
job does not pay the bills you have to
pay yeah you lose four in a row [ __ ]
that's a tough sell man you never get a
cyborg fight so I was like wife [ __ ]
hmm Casey crazy
what uh what DC say how great I was
getting great love that guy
yeah he just you know he's a bully just
trains like I mean you know I was
watching him work out and it's just
non-stop with that guy where's Maddie
see what it's doing too much you know
like he's out here training and it's
good and he's bounced it well you know
what John's doing just comfort his home
best trained partners in the world not
doing you'll see tonight not doing this
other stuff yeah where's me a little bit
he's got that wrestlers mentality where
he just Grimes old John doesn't I don't
know I don't know
well John took him down and beat him I
don't know hold on but John has always
had a reputation for not training as
hard
in fact I've talked people in this camp
say that him wrestle so I'm saying that
he sees you I've been in spokespeople I
just talk to people about that what I'm
saying is that John John's reputation is
not DC's reputation in terms of work
ethic DC is a complete look like you
just said it he might be doing - oh
you're saying
doing too much other stuff but his
training is non-stop as well he's a
maniac
I can say that I mean I know you just
saw him so did school no no no no that's
not from him that's what I heard you
know from people who train with him he
trains like his ass off
John Jones has been known to be a guy
from what I've heard you missed again
wait here he was a good point
so DC does train hard if you want trains
hard when John trains trains right now
he changed Johnson camp later on I'm
sure
so John's training trust me John
straining hard no matter what your
friend study John streaming's ass off to
win this fight DC I'm sure trains his
ass up
they're professionals one of them has
obligations to the UFC to do
commentating and you'll see the nya and
his name's not John Jones so I say
things worrying me I'm saying they all
train I thought you're saying he was
training too much like overnight no no
they all train about saying one of them
has other obligations outside of winning
a fight against John Jones his name's
not John right and John beat him before
without I am yeah it's that's what we're
he's made a DC yeah it to fits his but
if you know we can pull off with that
guy you thought you thought he daughter
lost his arm Michael Strahan yeah the
only guy who ever lost him you know so
III like I wonder what what it's such
such a great flight like what
adjustments are DC gonna make if that
fight wasn't that close field I can look
at it right well he's gonna be the same
John Orr's not all that ring Rus gonna
[ __ ] with him and then you know and then
there's the you sada accusations now so
so Maya my selfish my says that so as a
fan I want John I want a DC to win right
as a fan I like DC and I want them to
win but there's also another side of me
that says I really want to see John
Jones your cousin fight again now like I
feel like once y'all get that tune-up
fight that's not a tune-up fight not a
tuna fight once John if John does win
against DC vision Justin that's gonna be
exciting
how about John I see this is this is why
the conversation of the someone in the
crowd first pair around best you look at
the guys John speed and then he's going
to beat them to a second time how is he
not the best of all
well Gusterson call them the best of all
time I mean you know when I saw John
Jones grab DC around the hips and take
him down I think with a double leg
wasn't it a double a but I did yeah time
to grab you by the hips pick you up and
throw you to the ground it was like
complete are you that [ __ ] strong
you're taking four easy and put them on
his back and why are you freak
yeah so you know but let's see
because Gosselin looks as good as it
gets oh yeah I think about a girl soon
right now he is I mean that DC flexing
he's got his hands full you always have
your hands full with DC I could just
never get over
III think DC to me is the most
impressive fighter in many ways because
of his his stature he's not if you see
him like you see Lukey go looks like a
super athlete you see John Jones you see
gusts not seen these guys in person
they're Giants you see DC and he's
working out in a t-shirt
I'm sorry physically he's not he's five
nine you know undefeated as a
heavyweight almost done if it is a to a
fiver really I mean it's just
unbelievable and you've trained with
you're seeing fatal and personal now be
seeing different - yeah say well they
call they call do you see the black
failure you know that know a lot of
people do the xn so similar body similar
by not opposing like nothing like this
you wouldn't look in like oh my God look
at this freak right right no definition
that you know they call DC the black
fade or what's in there like another
nickname but that sounded really racist
because a fun play on ninja fatalism
something I don't know I just I just a
lot yeah I did hear for me on the black
fatal because he has that dadbod but
it's just this monster yeah looks like a
stocky guy yeah I did do some work in
outfit was like next week man do his
whole camp and uh Amsterdam with our boy
in the crown he's fighting it Jun yeah
good on that finishing have you talked
to Matt mineral um we text I don't know
he texted me when that spike knees
gotten out so I was doing them for that
Matt square garden card yes just taking
huh I like to ask them too many
questions but I'm sure I have to do the
fighter interviews out there so I'll
find out then
let's do some current events stupid they
keep it toasty in here it's a little
toasty toasty I think I know the name
now - um I don't want to sound racist at
all it's like fate fate or a million oh
yeah yeah oh that's what they call DC I
think I heard that you mean they they're
using the n-word not the bad word Negro
yeah a million Negro or something like
that
anyways I couldn't really say direct
mini-grant okay all right so the first
one is Dana White booking Kendrick Lamar
for his son's 16th Brad and money that's
super super money Jesus Christ and Rick
Lamar Kendrick Lamar Jesus hopefully I'm
TV does uh that's what everyone's saying
super sweet 16 we just anyone an [ __ ]
the 16 year old with have you ever seen
the six year old I'm not saying sons as
well you've seen the 16 year old ones 16
my sweet 16 now you throw just entitled
oh yeah I've seen him I've seen him
daddy I need an alligator I need a suit
all gold if I don't have em again free
yeah I wonder if Victor now time for the
camera but ya know I bet the [ __ ]
yeah Wow
Kendrick Lamar Dana's got some chaos for
little Wow what's that costume you think
five hundred it's a very good season uh
400 500 regret on our podcast he told us
that he dropped 1.2 million dollars for
a photograph in his office I looked at
the photograph that's an amazing
photograph room and he said yeah I I
said it too and I I wrote a 1.2 million
I hope that was on our podcast he'll
drop some money I remember some artists
I forgot which one but the really high
status artists would charge like a
million or two million to do private
events probably good I because I mean I
remember I mean I know what David Blaine
was charging back in the day for just to
go on somebody's yacht and do magic like
Gaddafi's son Gaddafi son was like bro
well my god Gaddafi sons gonna pay
whatever but like regular people
I heard Brianna did one thing and it was
like is a million dollars I think every
hour yeah you want to come to my side
you 500 grams yeah you wanted to come in
your house
I'm are like whew
Apple back in the day she had to go sing
five songs at somebody's house in
Beverly Hills I think she made like 250
something on Apple we don't I know her
see an apple in degrees was five grand
she such an amazing talent but in the 95
ours here she was in the cover of really
going to bring her on his own I can't
really name she is it she is a genius I
really long to see her me hear music the
to her first two albums are oh damn I'm
sorry go to her you know her right
I don't know her numbers no give me a
song she think she won't know what she
did he was you love her you would love
it her lips leather
oh yeah Fionna was feeling good song
this judge and give you a song you
two-bit son
she's an incredible talent put on a put
on sleep to dream when she was at 7:30
good wrote this room know just did not
give me the most famous songs I look
everyone counting Jack softer now
there's a good sound 20 no there we go
play that rhyme that's criminal
I just want the most famous one I would
give a [ __ ] she was nineteen singing
this right
[Music]
I know this is the one song I know yeah
she's cool man
I know if I want this play on my party
was just cool amazing she's still
touring yeah should you know Coolio and
without ice are still touring that
telling me I gather together and make
money to pay on Vanilla Ice new kids on
the block
yep boys de man River Hanson some
promoters and I handled it that moon
bobber do these little [ __ ] their
parents are Jesus's their managers and
whatever they got to be 14 agent of it
forty tell you out they four days
bringing my play 60 of each they they
sell so many ticket line because they
have their own fan base they built out
their own fan base yeah they have
retreats on Islands where people pay to
hang out with look at them there there
are the cuties and even they're probably
so good because they've been doing
nothing but playing music for so long
the same songs that ya hear you sang
songs with the Pricer chickie you tell
me the numbers smashing and making crazy
miles making fun of me the guy turns
nasal you you know what they what they
do like no I was like they're not dead
they didn't die goes now no how does
they have their own thing but they don't
they because again cuz I don't think
they're not doing it they do no press 20
years ago they don't go on America
you know gots down they don't go on the
Today Show they refused to do all that
because they already have these they
sell out if what you were talking about
there there are not there aren't they
super religious - no they're not he said
that huh that's what I thought it's all
still writing singing and playing
together at 36 34 31 good on them they
probably having a blast and they're
praying already doing it for 25 years
that's impressive
they parlayed that song nor they you
slob Bobby put out one of their songs
right now I want to see if they're good
let's just hear one of them's one of
them Hansen
were the new ones yeah I don't think
they sell music no they just kill it and
we can all two weeks ago
[Music]
okay I'm not mad at this get it talk to
this Brennan are you ready for my offer
for my birthday party hey David Hayes
ready what's it gonna cost Brennan hurry
don't brought three of them got me yeah
three Grand Prix I need to see more
money than a bad present my friends
would bully what if I put on a wig and I
think of those that was bad
just like this again they're telling it
man again you have no idea but the
[ __ ] smack making millions a year
instead we made a beer they've known
beer and hops my mom seems off if mom
hops there have more anytime merchants
there killed it you know sure the beers
are everywhere yeah make occasions that
I am
Australia is an untapped resource
another killer here oh my god another
they literally sell out everywhere man
yeah no I'm just saying so there's beer
they have their bear they're in here man
I thought they died dedicated fanbase
should we start [ __ ] taking these
equestions dude no no I don't have a kid
I know you think he's being banished my
jaw and the kid crazy is that though
um I would've thought not me not me
me neither what else gets in all right
uncle of glory had a kickboxing match
and this guy over here
Morel grown heart he ko it another guy
but he killed him in a way that the guy
just turned around for no reason yeah is
so weird so I'll girl playing shouting
here belt it looked like he thought he
hurt everyone
so here he turns around so he ko isn't
like why would he turn her I don't know
Bellary maybe honey we got hit so who
knows what's going on a little out of it
I'm guessing has to do you can't confuse
that for a bill hmm so he gets knocked
out and then a fan 2 fans come in and I
was growing a Warner wasn't his corner
they're fans all right so check out with
the fans dude oh wow yeah wow the fat
guys got money dump them any clock some
super hard and then a he said that he
probably thinks his jaws broken now
from the fan and the fan punches in
phrase well that's todd grisham
reporting on it man a little ahem the
fitness thing is that will feel or
realize that's Big Mike in his corner
Mike from Amsterdam whoo oh yeah he
trained Melvin man off over over him he
trained straight killers he's a big
scary dude that's as far that you hit
you see him jump in there that's not a
guy you want on your bad list any dude
no although those guys look like
fighters themselves or they often don't
that big mutt you need no big mutt
being like they're not hearing a peep
I'm sure but those two guys look like
thugs if you're going to jump in a ring
an attack guy like that and start
swinging like that
beautifly Myles like you began big night
for us with the toughest guys on the
planet well I don't know who those guys
are but think about two guys were going
to jump in and attack a guy they might
be headed to I've been friends training
partners are my friends well you know
what I watched that Ezra wood stain just
Elba did you watch it yeah when he
fought righteous Elba all right look
dude oh my god he would I figure what's
called but Elba he takes so he basically
gets ready to take a professional Muay
Thai fighting yeah and his best friend
is this big-time muy Thai boxers what's
it called
it's fighter so I think it's called
fighter uh he looks like a big athletic
guy man yeah it's called fighter [ __ ]
well yeah it's called slider uh so in
he's 44 years old
and he gets ready to take the fight and
his first time like God ah he's step is
[ __ ] and then he's on set to shooting
movies and training and this lot [ __ ]
really committed to it I mean he was
dead too
he had surgery on his back look [ __ ]
he won not need not to do that with a
body shot yeah I'm sure I don't think
the ending I didn't finish this so he
takes an amateur fighting it but he
literally he goes to Cuba to work with
the national boxing coach he does all
this stuff and then he goes and takes a
amateur muy Thai fight and he it's a
drawl and I'm like ah he look kind of
like [ __ ] and he's so embarrasses with
Dragic what the [ __ ] am i doing because
he's working his ass off and there's a
coach and then they from Big Mike's gym
they pick out this guy who was he's tena
Noah as an amateur want to know as a pro
and he's twenty-seven or thirty two idea
what he is and that was elbows first
fight in the England brick [ __ ] any
[ __ ] he'd knocks a dude out of the
body shot
it's very happy look at this he gets
rocked to own his amateur fight the dude
hits him in the uppercut low and walks
off like more cuts down not heels feels
down to the ground you getting [ __ ] up
too it was really important to be honest
I turned it on on the plane to almost
make to hate on him
other gamma watching me [ __ ] terrible
afters trying to fight watch I like is
it first like oh my god give me a
nightmare
yeah yeah really good he looks he looks
like an athletic [ __ ] he was
built he's like naturally unite Irian
he's lean for sure no he's lean did you
see the part where they were doing a he
went to Japan and they're doing pain
stuff on him have you ever heard of
those miserable but you believe that's
as old marché we just hit him hit him so
you we got slain yeah you wanted been
doing that for those for TV that's not
real yeah but it's real but no real
fighters would do that not yeah that was
just for the show that's what they look
like it's a producer saying hey why
don't we do this we have this idea
there's time he's all through cabin that
they're putting it on and his coaches a
legit ask coach owns a gym in England
and they're putting on him and he just
won't play he's like I need a [ __ ]
break he walks off and he's like Mike
that was the mic off and my coaches
literally like dude he can't do this
ain't the movie can't walk off you do
what the foot he tears it means I can do
it that's what the [ __ ] to do I'm not
gonna do this well I was interesting man
but yeah he [ __ ] I was really in porn
I mean he was like he said he's wanted
to do it forever like it's been a 44
have knocks to toe with us he it at
first he was a little hesitant he's
getting beat up Michael using it stops
didn't get knocked out she's a guy you
know did he fight like good you know
guys I can win the awards he fought but
still 10 another amateur that's real one
and I was a pro then Elba it just had
about indras elbows is [ __ ] it's fun
to watch only three-part series I was
all I needed to other kind of those
temperatures up and it just sim training
I'm gonna freak the [ __ ] out too much
this is what have all won it not matter
leave it yeah I believe it is really
connection intense guy
any spot I think he has been training
his whole life in one way or another no
he talks that he said he was doing
kickboxing to his 19 like he did it for
three years and then we got serious
about act and moved to New York and just
hasn't done it sick Wow
44 yeah Wow yeah so it was always
nagging our who's best friends the world
champion Oh Kate boxer okay and so he
was like mess around with his friends
stuff all the time he's always wanted to
do it but his best friend didn't coach
him now
that's his coach there his best friend a
coach and his best friend picked out his
opponent from Big Mike's gym wow so cool
it was cool man
oh yeah his [ __ ] impressed we had a
big thing that's a big milestone awesome
what else get you oh this is not not
related but did you watch you know we
had a bunch of shows to watch for that
long long flight yeah have you seen
Atlanta yes I watched if I never had
access to pretty good no I don't is
we're over Childish Gambino is real
names are Glover Glover Donald Glover
Donald Glover you know you get you get
this disconnects albums is last
challenge Gambino kid things just
controlled by Donald Glover which makes
so much more sense but you know how guys
have a rap name you're Donald Glover man
your helps your Donald Glover the actor
writer [ __ ] rapper and I go like
yours him only really is up here he's so
[ __ ] talented top five musician right
he's such a monster right now God and
he's got his own show right here does
everything got a producer ex an accident
right instead he's a leak it's so
difficult and you know how he started
rapping Tina Fey his rap on set in
between takes Tina Fey's like you you
have to do someone music you have got to
do some of this nice
what what show is he on with her I
wasn't okay no he's on a he's on a show
he's on 30 rock
he's I'm very wrong I remember I'm on 30
rock some pretty rockin shoes I don't
watch shows yeah Wow
small small role Wow kids amaz amazing
all right the next one is this shark
showed up in 3 feet of water off of the
Baja California Mexico coast
Wow I'll show you a little bit of a I'd
like to see that it looks reducta kit
like a 15-foot shark great white this
one focus thought it was a whale you're
it's a whale not getting that close yeah
not either dude
so it's this enormous shark the video is
really long but I'll show you with this
gift right here so you see his head pop
ups in oh my god and what happened was
it was hit by a boat propeller oh the
back so broke either back it was just
right without that thinners are here the
dorsal fin it was just like cut through
in the back right there [ __ ] man yeah
someone go put misery meet sushi then I
don't know what they look I can't just
leave the poor thing good so I [ __ ]
bad enormous pay but also don't get hit
by the boat man look at that if your
giant fish and hear the goddamn bus
don't get drunk yeah oh yeah John that
sucks though man yeah I tore a thing now
it's more sad let me than anything yeah
look at that poor thing man you can't
[ __ ] move you see that character yeah
that's a bummer
that's [ __ ] up his friends we can beat
him [ __ ] a lot of things guys I think
Beach right now is it on the sand there
yeah I guess it is least three feet it
will go from 3 feet to 6 feet and back
to 3 feet can't really move yeah they
said that they think he's going to this
shallow area to eat stingrays because he
doesn't have the energy and lions yeah
and it was an hour for diet and then
what was hoping this dumbass Cameron be
dumb enough to get closer you'd eat him
Hong Kong Kong dude checking down a
short secure look at that time stupid
humans um you know who came to my show
in Sydney a guy named Adam green tree
you heard of me some of the best hunters
in the world saw the picture you these
are boys campaigns they go riding off
them like shooting
in the face yeah rogon right now is in
Hawaii with a bunch of bow hunters
they're like a group of them well bad
guys put me and rode on a group message
is like a check on doing that bow thing
right and then I do the three of us
haunting you no doubt let's uh yes just
tell me when and now it is the four
seasons in the area or how's that
because the zero actors like hang out
with guys during the day and then I'll
go back to for season well you guys
sleep on the rock so how does that work
and then you guys shoot the beer in the
face and I'll just not do I'll be in the
tree waiting I have with my shucks I
don't like seeing bears die is there any
way we can do that with my eyes shut
yeah I don't mind killed err no interest
is the fair man and his wife was a smoke
show so I Adam but you know that I think
it's not regulation time so anything
dangerous there I was asking them he's
like yeah dude we'll shoot damn it not
doing that they climb like they can't
kill me so I have no interest in doing
that want some that session but shoot
kill me somebody goes buffaloes I got a
lot of [ __ ] wild boar wild boar I'd be
down a kid leaning against I'm like
they're his wild boar couch look at that
all relaxed and was a boy I'd be down
that things but he's got a bag stash you
said again he said same thing can paint
said he said [ __ ] uh Buffalo well
there another bus look at that right
there they said by far the most danger
oh yeah oh yeah would you the size that
run that thing is a bad thing in here in
a [ __ ] peep out of anybody the length
of its horns are as long as he is man
but you saying the hide is like [ __ ]
crazy thank you you're gonna be on I was
like elbow I'll be on oh yeah I mean on
I mean yeah be on your back right I'll
be watching it on YouTube is what I mean
by the on I'm down to go we'll pull up
Hogzilla right up there hey there you go
that's Hogzilla right there bro was you
with a 12-2 long lesson news on in it
think that long snoot man that's why
they use hogs pigs to find truffles
because they're I'm six feet under the
ground I like to determine short hairs
and and pigs picks it up it one little
big notes you're happy what's nice yeah
it's a hard animal you know what the
nose isn't though the fur is the nose is
refreshing you know it feels almost like
think of it as an old dried out peach in
the south shore
one little wet oh they want me land on
it they would use Kent which for the
company would make brushes and
toothbrushes out of boar bristle yeah so
they used to use boar bristle late and
Johnny liked abortion out and I have a
hard time shooting that thing in the
face yeah unless unless is in danger and
it's coming up coming well you got to
call you a wild boars apparently because
they they breed lack mother fibro huh
you know I've been boar hunting there
what I went boar hunting when in Hawaii
really stirring clot and I I didn't tell
you the story Oh on what you use Spears
I know they gave me a gun and you shoot
I shot but iced well no I didn't miss uh
before we leave another corner I saw a
baby pour and it was the cutest thing as
I've seen I went you know I'm not
killing that thing or it's my mother so
I decided to do is leave the light on
the bump you know everyone we out front
yeah I'd put it to the side so they
would warn him and I talked haze it up
there they took good your semi we caught
not zero the guy goes and you were all
he and the the the leader taking us the
tour guide he's all dude I I apologize
man but you guys are the first ones
that's never killed any boy I just got a
pause here we come and every time you
better not be over there it's exactly I
did hey and then when we and then when
we got in the car least was like [ __ ]
man oh what a waste a [ __ ] time I see
anything
I once me a cloud was what in it I saw a
bunch I was spooking in the whole bunch
I turned my line I was extra loud in
cosmos def are so [ __ ] loud yeah when
he catch [ __ ] I thought it was fun man I
smell bacon you guys better not be up
there I feel like Adam here I come for
asking around feel like Adam and Rogan
would tie me up and feed me to look
[ __ ] long if I did that ah [ __ ] eh be
quiet not a lot of dog peepers out you
keep the boys down oh and by the way
don't be moving too much either because
I was dizzy I'm a fidgeter yeah yeah and
all that nylon alright I was making
noise with the nylon you got to stay
still I'm affinor hear you oh yeah
mean you're made for them yeah man
chatty everyone got a cavity shot my so
we like to chat I figure you cold - yep
and I sleep on ice one beds in the four
C's huh
so if that's hunting let me know yeah
you know for season has like a horrible
warthog prom I'll go down then shoot
some pig sure but until then from my
tower yeah and from my penthouse until
then it's gonna be tough
yeah let's get you got you shot Adam
green tree and I'm greedy tree here's a
cute little dog so this police dog got
fired because those two friendly that
makes sense at the Malinois that's a
that's a very small puppy so I guess I
don't know started training that's a
shepherd I'm gonna go ahead and say it's
a mountain oh it's a shepherd that's a
shepherd sandwich kind of Shepherd
that's what it was a baby but now and
now it's a has a new job and it's a
greeter for the governor of Queensland
there's just too damn friendly friendly
right well yeah looks tough what can you
do not what you want you want a tough
looking dog but that's friendly he must
have been so goddamn fairly worth a key
we can't work with this thing yeah might
be gay we'll never think of that I just
not going to look why are you saying the
gate dogs are friendly because like it
was yet with the other but I mean in
he's all like whoa and then he's mean to
the women haha like why the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] Baxter barking all the window I
know I never thought the JumpShip was a
game out here no although my friend has
a son who when he was five and six was
very much that way real friendly with
guys yeah okay
nothing wrong with that yeah yeah that's
not a phase Brian no I was it was very
apparent that he was very sort of taken
with the male figures in the room and a
female your nose at all doing yeah
whatever yeah yeah it did yeah and I was
like and secretly you know that thought
bubble over your head you're like well
your son is clear there's a problem yeah
no it's all good but I'm just saying
since you how you can see these things
very early on yeah in life history
because they're born like that yeah some
are born some it's like bad swing sets
is lead to UM like molestation so my dad
might bring
it out my buddy who we were talking
about Wonder Woman being this phenomenon
second week in a row
you know Patty's in friend of ours and
she's she's be I think she's a
successful successful female director as
far as like the biggest opening and
holding at Crate they've already made
two hundred and fifty million dollars
kill it
yeah and what the [ __ ] was I going to
said was I talk you give her a shout out
every pocket hold I don't know it was
about oh yeah buddy goes my buddy goes
can you believe this Wonder Woman I
can't believe it
I go yeah man it's amazing a go did you
ever watch his kid he goes I'm gay I
don't know anything about her invisible
rope I don't know anything about her
bracelets either I was never looking at
that stuff and I did not care that they
blocked bullets I just loved the way she
looked at so it's all funny he knew
everything about her I was like alright
I heard it's really really good really
good yeah it's great well yeah chin how
about this one
this seventeen year old teenager was
stealing a bike that dude caught him and
they do was a tattoo artist so he
tattooed on his forehead
I like I'm a thief or something oh my
god that's so intense
yeah and it's legit they hold him down
and make him do that yes two guys
damn so the guy that did it obviously is
going to jail now yeah we yeah I mean
yeah he's also 779 out so if they looked
like they worked his ass before
also you know that's mean as [ __ ] so me
like like that's bullying to the [ __ ]
yeah ten catties [ __ ] he's up for 17
now the kids [ __ ] man yeah he's gotta
get lasering it out kid like in laser
that all that doesn't come off right
lasers off what she'll get it where it
in Brazil Brasilia [ __ ] man
there was a threaten him with his life
or something for him to support and take
that yeah otherwise yeah that's also a
little overkill don't be a dick it's
just your [ __ ] bike yes just a bike
he's also 17 if it was 40 like stealing
your girl's wedding ring suddenly I get
it but this yeah got dog nose like he's
fast when you're super fun yes I think
we could do I could wear a hat no no I
can get it off can they make it come off
the early no no they can't I don't know
no they don't know that's I don't it
still it shows up
as white so on his forehead that still
gonna look pretty it'll do look better
they get fade it to completely get rid
of it it's still not really Lance what
most people do is they so they get the
laser and it just looks like it's burnt
in your skin now like white Ryan they
cover it with another tattoo but yeah so
it's gonna look you're gonna see trace
of it but for sure they make you write B
they make it look better
yeah with laser yeah but but yeah maybe
it's just he's still going to like when
he gets flushed you're going to see an
outline says I'm a thief does it still
be 17 yeah she's not into hate
yeah I don't know man
let's look them what else should go to
know um how about this teacher so she
this teacher had sex with she don't lot
she's 25 years old you know she's also
my teachers why yeah I think it was like
spongebob
she's so hot and also don't arrest her
so two of them were 17 one was 16 but
check her out here
she's a time supply teacher that's her
she's so hot why would you arrest her
for real well I'm not going away what
city is this North Carolina I don't know
what city in well I want to find out
where she is in jail me too I want to
slide in them DNA yeah don't be a dick
she's 17 those kids are psyched she's 25
yeah great there the boys are the boys
are not traumatized they are loving it
hey once do it tell me that would many
things once you showed up it's very
shocking appalling a person would do
that to a student says the lady says the
nerd they didn't get you didn't get tail
don't be jealous
do you give my cheese the captain the
football team in a in and suck his dick
after class I'm appalled god she's hot
God don't look at her that a tip yes
good free I'm in here and make all of
these all because I'm a huge fan of her
McCall's sorry everybody Mike thank you
really
she's gorgeous dog she hey Maxim let go
I'm gonna deal with this - how long she
how long are they gonna keep her in jail
life I don't know no come on man
I'm gonna hire her as my nanny
immediately not him that's the wrong
thing to say
because my kids are very young but I'm
just saying and I'm out here to talk
with her does a lot of good oh I hear
you though I'm going to dress up like a
17 year old I'm gonna start wearing fan
what kind of teacher but caring scale
kind of weird teacher [ __ ] of students
let's be honest let's get real for
Cygnus I don't know it's some kind of a
sector that had a signal to me like god
damn I love me a piece of that some of
the boys are you know probably athletic
and strong and tall 17 you're not
getting the least bad breath what if you
have a dad they said well no no more
erotic 17 year old athlete that's a good
athlete
oh sure rope for a woman yeah you know
you're a homo right yeah oh I'm safer
like a big six year olds really us like
them like really good at sports I think
I yes you might be attracted to young
[ __ ] young energetic smooth muscular
horrible supple full mouth boys what I
you don't we start with you at all I'm
not inviting you I mean [ __ ] those
bullets saying it's me I'm just saying
that young men is it's well known can
keep their dig rock art for a good four
hours maybe that's what she's into a
young supple man with no hair who just
got his pubes I'll see you at 17 listen
man there's some good-looking [ __ ]
young seventeen year old high school
students I mean they're probably some
great looking hundred eighty-five pound
linebackers restless Restless get a
lesson how big can you be it's between
games you can be big you do nothing
about how damn big oh yeah yeah so the
next one is Tom Hardy's in the talks for
a live-action Disney movie and the
person directing it is Guy Ritchie and
oh he's gonna be Jeff are Tom are gonna
play Jafar will smith is the genie oh I
don't know do you know that Gus is
completely different but you know we'll
know yeah Will Smith is the genie in
Aladdin the one that they're going to
redo are we doing okay and that is this
the same movie so it's not about of why
backbone so are they doing another
animation or are they doing a live
actual mission yeah I think they're
doing a new one okay so this listen for
a live action come party is Devon and
Guy Ritchie's directing it
I love Guy Ritchie does anyone else in
it I mean I get Brian to play appeared
in this but
Jaffar come on man remember Jeff on ok
yeah [ __ ] our Islands all my favorite
[ __ ] movies I'm surprised he put Will
Smith as the genie when I heard that
yeah anyone you gotta replace Robin
Williams yeah
tough gig naughty so they went
completely opposite Jeannie black now
Jeannie black to your Black Keys were
traditionally black actually in certain
all those fellas this one's blue okay so
know what I mean by that is that black
people are magic that's all right
what no I'm saying that all black doing
oh man yeah that's all I'm saying black
magic black every good it's not the good
magic it's not white magic
um like honestly 204 zippers in Eugene I
don't see I don't see Tom Hardy as
Jabbar I don't see Will Smith is a genie
either so I guess that hey just a few
offers everybody now you lose all
privileges your braces at 50 and you're
provided by July even visualising to the
15 have a herpe instead of the herpes
I'm cetera that you have zero root cause
hi it's not first of all you won't kill
everyone call them Invisalign Tom Cruise
warm yeah braces they're Invisalign and
not a Tom Cruise just falls right from
Tom Cruise and your per piece of metal
are fees what is that
it's a cold sort outside what it is it's
an irritation because the [ __ ] the
plastic cut my lip there so put it in
the plastic suit yes I'm sure you let
I'd file it down it hurts like a
[ __ ] you need to put those in
right now I'm not doing it why because I
can't because I'm big I can I guess and
it really bothers me but do they say how
many hours you have to wear my day I
supposed to wear I'm 22 hours a day
well bhai here's our two hours yeah we
um the rest of the day and I got hope
it's worth it I've gotta get him checked
out and can you eat with them no you
can't you gotta take them out when you
eat and you gotta brush your teeth put
it back in were they expensive sleep
with them - really expensive $5,000
she's tired terrible deal once you get
the metal ones like Frank camera become
dead serious because I'm not where do
you [ __ ] metal braces bro
it'd be so much cooler if you did do
they still do metal yes sometimes but
you have to do in this in this line
that's plan
stick forget cheaper I know but get
cheaper so kids in high school don't
have to wear [ __ ] metal braces yeah
well no you can do payment plan like 422
a month or something like that just a
lot man for kill a lot in parents but
they always said break my parents you
know for that my brother races were
always expensive braces were they're
like well we're going on vacation this
year but we couldn't cause the braces
we're gonna buy cars here we couldn't
cuz the braces are not five grand
my brother had four oh seven years sorry
really drew that for effort ah this team
living here look great now though just
it'll be a damn half his life merit
seven years in my uncle with our des
monts I'm six months one and done
but let's see that's Invisalign yeah man
but maybe that's what's so expense cuz
yeah we're so fat it works fast it's not
for sure make that less what did what
didn't feel good was them filing didn't
like it got to make some Rome sex she
was like this woman's like yeah we have
to make some room for you I was like
what she got a file in there and filed
in the middle of my teeth I was like
what what are you doing hi Don I know
you got a create room in your mouth the
whole thing drives me crazy see no I'm
not trying to be a dick again but they
see anything about whitening does that
even get brought up otherwise let me
know what dentist not to go hey bro it's
a step-by-step process okay man while
that's not law it was because I'll put
teeth whiter in your in braces I don't
know and because I'm busy oh yeah that
busy could put teeth light in there I
don't know if that's how it works sir
it's not a bad idea though alright man
UH one step at a time like I said please
let me just get my hair straight bro I'm
already going dealing with a lot
emotionally with my mouth is it hurting
it this thing doesn't feel good on the
side of my mouth to load the hurt yeah
and don't call it her you guys this bug
himself god damn it ah shut the hum
hearted playing Jafar well that's get
you um do you guys watch this show
bachelor I don't but this guy does I do
I've you know about this controversy I
do and I'm not mad at her at all she's
hot so bachelor in paradise I guess one
of the contestants a
black dude and one of the contestants a
white girl they were getting sexual
together they didn't really do it but
they were I guess he was licking her veg
said soft courtly said if we referred to
a softcore porn it's all on camera doll
on camera and then go ahead chin go
ahead so a producer felt really really
uncomfortable about it because she was
too drunk that's what the producer said
a field producer said that the female
was too drunk you thought that she was
too drunk or he or she uh no if it was a
guy or girl but he thought that she was
too drunk so they shouldn't have
videotaped it they should have stopped
it from happening however sources close
to the matter say that she was all about
it at the time I'm sure and then now he
came to him
by the way ah so so don't don't give
that guy a hard time no no she did not
okay so go ahead say in this now she's
saying she didn't consent to anything
sexual with this - [ __ ] he's [ __ ] and
he's black oh and she's got a voice they
said she has a boyfriend she would never
do this on foot I mean [ __ ] she's drunk
so it was a little bit this what I heard
I saw they were both drinking got really
drunk she approached him Carol to him
started making out they go to a room and
the base doing softcore porn he you know
he's licking her she's obviously fine as
[ __ ] and the producer who's doing it
feels uncomfortable quit the next day
sues ABC or whether it's on saying he
should have to sit through this or she
should not sit through that the entire
series is cancelled now and now home
girl does oh I have a boyfriend well I
don't want to do this what a conduct and
barb or boy [ __ ] Demario jackson III
agree man I think I think it sounds like
she was I didn't see it right I don't
know anything about it but if she was if
she went to him and she got drunk and
she was like what he don't be
what do you know here's another thing
for you I'm not playing so I'm not
putting side to her but let's just add
this up she also took all her clothes
off and gentleman pool naked with him
yeah and they said she appeared to be
lucid and fully engaged then holding
getting making out yeah you wanna
[ __ ] come on down oh you want to ruin
his life we didn't get hurt no he
couldn't do it because it's too drunk
Hudson [ __ ] he was drunk - yeah they're
both drunk
everybody's responsible for their
behavior if you get that drunk and you
engage and you get the pool naked with
somebody and things happen you're not
probably charged against him though no
you're not I had a boyfriend okay does
she know the job well you bring the show
put the whole show scam just trying to
make money whole shows cancer I don't
know listen she's embarrassed
she got drunk did Tony she didn't want
to do everybody's embarrassed but also
if you have a boyfriend
don't go ambassador paradise I agree run
bachelor I'm trying to dig down and
you've got some good-looking dudes like
you know this guide to Mario
good-looking dude Rossi tried hooking up
with he's very cute too
I don't know I I beasty shows with you
dude is he he might been the one this is
hilarious I was watching the new one and
it's a black Bachelorette for the first
time so how do you watch it or someone
that's checking the race on whose
favorite is your black but um there's
the first time there's african-americans
a Bachelorette and well they're Kotik
it's a little kind of cliche what to do
it so racist to be honest there's a lot
of black guys a lot of white guys and
they play basketball and of course the
white guys were terrible and there's one
black I just dumped in the ball and
everyone dominating and to make clichés
and stereotypes even worse his
girlfriend rolls in she's all what are
you doing uh-oh before he won the show
you [ __ ] me now you're hearing he's on
I never met her in my life oh no I'm the
girl in the bachelorettes like hold on
and they have a sit-down and she's like
dude I forget his name it might be
tomorrow might be this guy cuz that
looks like you've been with the head
bang on she's like dude last time I saw
you you [ __ ] she said this on camera
that's not I saw you [ __ ] me if keys
to my house is alright we did [ __ ] but
and I do have keys but you know we're
not together and they're like doing this
back and forth she kicked him off the
show obviously I just thought yeah real
racist that they have all these black
guys they play basketball they do the
locker room tons of chicken wings and
then the black guy happens to have a
girlfriend yeah you know I'm saying I
just it didn't make him look good in so
good and let him I guess like they say
my real ain't golf now golf now and then
the guest speaker Kareem abdul-jabbar
okay
yeah it's not like when lobsters like so
black yeah
rather like I remember I didn't have one
black guy this year hola it's the black
Oscars now bachelor it was like we did
they're right we haven't had a token
black girl they're being [ __ ] for it
right and then they just went [ __ ]
balls deep this episode the batch was
brought to you by loves and chicken
wings if I saw are you certain gives you
some great drink I was like what the
[ __ ] is happening right now they did a
little anything but it's exactly what
they did
intro song brought to you by little
Wayne I was like what in the world is
happening you like coughs hear of little
Wayne does it's not just for when you're
sick anymore usually Chris does the
hosting but this time we got Flavor Flav
no weird why aren't you wearing a giant
clock on you you know what time it is
it's Flavor Flav we fired Chris he's
just a wolf [ __ ] yeah it was so
inch and I was like ah they are really
playing the black stereo plan yeah that
sounds pretty crazy alright well I don't
know though this can't be fine since you
get home girls just crying River cuz she
got caught in she's cheating on her man
not matter as long as she doesn't sue
for like sexual assault she walked
through the video hey that video for
binge on I heard her being the aggressor
her jump in the pool and Finance biddies
and that ass and him jump in the pool
you know a good lawyer would have a
field day with that
oh good lord like hold on white girl
takes off all her clothes drunk jumps in
the pool my black client you think he
wanted to be in the pool like just so
much easier my buddy got sued for sexual
harassment because he said something so
innocuous he said um he said something
to really really innocuous like she's
got this great dress on and she was on a
bike and she was talking about a story
and goes she goes I feel uncomfortable
she had a history of doing this and so
she reported him for sexual harassment
because I feel I'm kind of all ran out
so he got put on paid leave he couldn't
go to the office until it happened so
six months later
0kay hired a lawyer they said once
they'd leave yeah they did she did him
up yeah but you know what he does he
does work where he should be there and
he does it for other people so he works
with
uh foster kids and so yeah it was a
problem so he hired a woman lawyer who
was a complete badass who specializes in
these things mr. Sood he said she
thought that her Ilan he got her up on
the stand he said you're gonna lie if
you think there's any product when you
get there's a good lawyer across three
you didn't think of everything believe
me they're professionals it's like me
being a ring with Luke Ross I've heard
of them
first time I've been to ring this guy's
in the ring with yet they they and this
lawyer he said dude I was so shocked
because he's aware - oh he's aware - but
he said do I get paid leave yeah he's a
little heath lawyer by training so he
has his law degree
why well he's a lawyer in the worst for
foster kids yes he then did he set you
assault the fun oh no no no no no he's a
lawyer but he has his law degree but he
now works with foster kids oh that's
right
so he's just aware of my training oh
good this woman does this she does this
odd whoo he said she [ __ ] dissected
this woman this woman basically
literally crumbles all unhappy and quick
she crumbled but what have run beloved
dirt weapons with him he was a hundred
percent fine he was reinstated and this
woman was completely defacing a fire
I believe they fired if I would - yeah
she's I would chili honor sir I fire
encounter sir she's a huge liability
yeah it'd be tough to you the job - if
that's like her track record I wouldn't
want in my office yeah I wouldn't I
think if you do that you're trying to
ruin somebody's life and I think you
should let people decide for yep
yeah and there are people out there that
want to do that to you little scared -
or how about this one
a guy's freed after 17 years in prison
oh because you know it was for an
aggravated robbery and it was based off
an eyewitness account and then turns out
there's another guy by the way this is a
weird case so the other guy looks just
like them and you see a picture of him
here side-by-side in the day oh my god I
profile can't blame God you can't plan
the eyewitness at all that's crazy and
they believe the cops are trying to
influence them because look at these uh
pictures that they have for the witness
oh hell no you can't see the other guy
that's yeah a little tough but bro
that's cool that's yeah that's kind
that's that's ridiculous all the other
pictures are dark thirty like and you
don't gotta sell to me is so homeboy
spent seventeen years of prison in his
life they go hey good news we [ __ ] up
here's here's your reward
get out well money know you'll get that
money you'll get money do you oh yeah
you get money - yes oh I know I know a
guy who went to jail for 25 years and he
went away with 16 and you didn't you and
they are getting to the gun no and
they're giving him 25 million dollars so
Wow
and I was talking to him about what it's
gonna be twenty five million dollars
yellow prison he got his first
installment which is five million
recently days that he laid out yeah and
now he's out there looking for houses in
nice neighborhoods after being in I'm
sorry in California State Penitentiary
416 I know you met him you might not
need any momentum with me
uh yeah yeah great a guy and so you soon
you're twenty five million or there's go
my batter's 25 mil ah long me wait go oh
I don't know the details but I know that
he was granted twenty five million
dollars and he like he thinks somebody's
been in jail for that long I talked to
him long time about what state
California State Penitentiary breaks up
in the gangs and stuff like that is
pretty well but you think that something
like that would look really terrible he
looks fantastic
he he's got like he's muscular t37 oh
yeah yes I'm like that you know forty
really wild man Jesus yeah this boy yeah
those people I always wanted to they
give them a money candle shows i watch
they don't make the half-hour I'll give
you money
hey I didn't know they could be twenty
five mil yeah I don't know that much but
although some how much it hurts in
Kalihi boxes I don't think he got
anything he probably did they have a lot
of those beads said they have a lot of
insurance for these things I mean yeah
the LAPD pays out a lot of my out of
court
yeah that's crazy I have no idea yeah
little sketch in mistakes happen I go
one more that's that's that's an
understandable now wouldn't you try I
mean that's tough come on don't blow
they'd like a criminal sheriffís came
first name too and they're from this no
like oh really close by in Kansas City
do they look identical Regina writes the
real criminal yeah the guy on the left
so the guy the right is one of that
released
oh [ __ ] what the dangle yeah I guess
other way around I think isn't it the
other guy he says he's not guilty either
so they have to put him to draaga yeah
so who knows what's gonna happen here
there's another guy but there wasn't
enough evidence suggesting layers yeah
it's me tough to prove the other guys is
right shout out to that dance [ __ ]
him
hey 25 mil coming your way can't Lee
what else yet alright this is the last
one a Coast Guard pulled a dude and his
dog from a duct-taped built boat that he
made a dad and make your boat out of
duct tape as I expected and go far so
that was on Mythbusters and duct tape
like that is made of metal so it's it's
amazingly good so you can it can work
for a while this guy's still floating in
the picture yeah it's amazing it's
amazing you can actually float for a
long time apparently not well enough
though or maybe he just didn't make a
good enough one well by the way near
Juneau Alaska now that water is cold
night is so cold there in that water for
ten minutes you will see you later
you will die [ __ ] you will die in this
summer by the way you that water's crazy
cold
oh yeah some people love duct tape I've
never been that guy whose balls even
touch people I see people with wallets
and purses [ __ ] realize when I robbed
somebody you see those people duct tape
stuff we're just all about birthday at
friends high school like make sure
there's everything solve everything [ __ ]
off pull out some doctor yeah relax got
a hole in your shoe let me help you out
it's weird yeah they saved here if
you're in a survival situation duct tape
I bet that gray silver silver silver' is
over there that's just good for
everything telogen I did it piss so hard
I got this dog this person will come
back into a dropping knowledge hurt it's
so hot so uh so uh tell me when my
dropping knowledge is about Pareto's law
you know about proto's law adult who's
explained pretty interesting a listener
be Fredo peretta was a an Italian
economist and he noticed while he was
gardening that 20% of his pea pods
produced 80 percent of his Peas hard
wooden pod some hard work and pauses
just riding the pine then he started
doing some more research and he was like
wow wait 20% of the population of a
owns 80% of land in Italy they started
looking at certain businesses they found
that 20% of the employees we're
producing 80% of the production though
and so it goes and it actually turned
out to be kind of a law and sometimes
20% of you know your workforce are
causing 80% of your problems so the idea
is that when you're running a business
or your own life try to figure out what
20 percent of your effort is causing 80%
of your results the same thing to be
done for working out or for your health
or for your energy or for whatever that
parentis principle applies to a lot of
things across the board the truth is
that usually 20 percent of your effort
is causing 80% of your results and maybe
maybe that 20% maybe there are those two
people so a lot of business people are
saying they spend also 80% at a time on
five really difficult clients but
they're only getting 20% return so they
fire those they just get rid of those
clients and their business booms and
it's the same thing when you're managing
your life so Baretta's principle can be
applied to your life apparently and many
people have talked about how that's
helped so look it up Pareto's law very
interesting and I think today that a
freaking economist would be gardening
and come up with this amazing law that's
still yeah like it's still applied to
science and still alive now but now 1896
super yeah it's all cool ebrill it's
old-school but pretty cool love it man
all right kids I can solve you very
quickly I'm going to be tomorrow doing a
charity for my friend Dave out named his
family
Dave's having a hard time he's got to go
have this major spinal operation so at
the last factory tomorrow we are doing
stand-up I was Loveline is on that yeah
I'd love you to be involved but you have
to say that yeah you got a set but we're
going to do this this gig and we're
raising money so come to the Laugh
Factory please this for a really good
ending and he's a great comic it is
going to be at 8 o'clock at the Laugh
Factory so come on down there's some
money raise some money please for the
best
yeah it's gonna be bedridden for two
months yeah I exported languish in
vessel yeah he had spina bifida as a kid
he's got lots of health property Dillman
hopefully yes he's always in pain just
really quickly he's always in pain he's
think about luck you are and he the pain
is so much that he breaks out in
shingles and stuff but this operations
gonna take the pain away just huge there
this boom go see Brian laughs factory
next week Thursday night I am at Gotham
comedy club there are less than 20
tickets left for that [ __ ] is sold out
let's keep this train going I have never
not sold out a big round breakdown live
this one should be special
I'm there for Bellator live in New York
City mass square garden but that
Thursday night it's June 22nd Gotham
comedy club I will be there slinging
jokes slab and [ __ ] and breaking down
fights chief at kake.com for everything
and we are releasing the T fat K summer
tees and tanks this week we are doing it
Wednesday 5 o'clock Pacific time
everything you've ever needs t fat K dot
Tom I think that's it brother
hurry back good to be back Ozzie kid is
back this is the finally kid to get his
braces we're out